National Sleep Foundation recommends
that adults aged 18 to 64 get between 7
& 9 hours sleep per night I'm probably
right in the middle that right around 8
I need my sleep I'm enjoying a little
siesta these days too like 12 minutes I
love it anyway a new infographic has
come out showing what successful people
from right now to the past how much
sleep they got so let's take a look so
there's some really interesting stuff
here Bill Gates averages seven hours of
sleep which is right sort of at the
front end of what the Sleep Foundation
is recommending billionaire Donald Trump
Anna I know you love Donald Trump am i
right you love Donald Trump he gets
about three to four hours of sleep he
then spent the rest of his day arguing
with eggs on Twitter Margaret Thatcher
got only four hours of sleep per day
this one I think is really interesting
Nikola Tesla who is the grandfather of
electricity slept for only two hours
each night Winston Churchill he did four
hours and then he knew the 90-minute nap
I want to talk about naps in a second
and interestingly and not surprisingly
politicians are the group of people who
get the most with more than nine hours
of sleep each night we know they're not
working and they're pretty much asleep
at the job so I don't know if that
counts in that so let's just start with
the personal angle like how important is
sleep to you guys can I have problems
getting to sleep like I would like to
sleep more but I'm definitely a night
person and I worry at night and I can't
sleep and wake up early for the Rubin
report taping uh but it is important
like I feel a lot better my mind moves
better I look better yeah that's
actually what I'm more concerned about I
feel like I function fine on four to
five hours of sleep I average between
five and six and when I sleep more than
that I'm actually groggy the entire day
so all these studies frustrate me a
little bit because everyone's different
yeah and so I don't like it when people
tell me oh you're only getting six hours
of sleep it's actually destroying your
cognitive abilities no it destroys my
cognitive ability is when I've slept
eight hours and then I wake up and I
just want to go back to sleep right and
everyone's your to your point I mean
that graphic shows the plenty of highly
productive people that are getting very
little sleep
although among those who don't get
enough sleep you have Margaret Thatcher
and Donald Trump I
know that I was just pulling what were
you know we can throw the graphic back
up for just a second we'll just keep
talking so people can see who else is on
there I like the Tesla fact right there
two hours that song in German
right after think about the [ __ ] that he
was getting done I had some serious
problems psychologically as well yeah
remember that time I mean he's a
brilliant man undoubtedly but he did
have his issues by the way so Barack
Obama gets six hours which is a little
on the low side yeah go ahead I just
have to make a point about Berlusconi
the reason why Berlusconi only got two
to four hours of sleep is cuz he was
[ __ ] prostitutes with a lot
prostitutes don't let you sleep they
charge when you're sleeping what do you
guys make a little what do you make of
the UH
if you're with the prostitute you know
to me like if you charge in two hours no
I don't know what you mean I'm just
saying generally prostitutes they charge
you for the whole time so if you're
gonna sleep through it
you know you mean get your value you got
it right well Berlusconi was
specifically known for his bunga bunga
parties yeah which I loved covering him
he was great um what do you guys make of
the politicians they get a lot of sleep
they don't work they get a lot of sleep
they pass laws so that they're buried
they pay less tax like what come on I
feel like I chose the wrong career I
love what I'm doing but I feel like I
would live high off the hog if I was a
politician
so you should become like a gerbil by
the way I don't really want to do it
right like a mid-level congressional
somebody not everybody would know about
you but you could sleep on yesterday I
was like toying with the idea of serving
on the Los Angeles City Council I'm like
it sounds like it'd be fun it right yeah
well it and if I know one thing about
Ana it's not like she has a lot of
controversial things she said that could
possibly derail her campaign but who
knows anyway how much sleep do you guys
get how important is sleep in your
day-to-day operation let us know in the
comments right down